round nine of the u.s. chess  championships was one for the ages  tournament co-leader Wesley so produced  a scintillating masterpiece against  Jeffrey Zhang in a game that will be  remembered as one of the finest ever  played in championship history former  champ Alexander honest truth under Cara  Nakamura to win his game for the chakra  off the round was fabiano caruana  blowing a two-point advantage and then  blundering badly to lose his game  against co-lead of erosion acromion  leaving bar still tied atop the  leaderboard it's the penultimate round  of the most shocking national  championship in years round 10 action  starts right now